[Musik]
morgendliche Übung an einem freundlichen
Herbsttag beim erlebnisregimentet 70
Kilometer westlich der schwedischen
Hauptstadt Stockholm geübt wird die
abwehrfeindlicher panzereinheit mit
Minen es ist mit 1.300 Angehörigen ein
großes Regiment und ein besonders
fortschrittliches Aufgabenbereiche
cyber-aktivitäten via Internet
Kommunikation fernkriegsführung und auch
Meteorologie und Ozeanographie für alle
Waffengattung her Marine und Luftwaffe
geschützt wird das Regiment auch von
einfachen Soldaten in und Soldaten
Wehrpflichtige wie diese für ihre
Ausbildung ist der junge Offizier Max
Lindblum verantwortlich er kennt seine
Truppe
klar denken auch viele hier daran dass
es ernst werden könnte
aber ich glaube vor allem dass die Moral
gestiegen ist auch durch die neue
nicht nur bei der Truppe sondern auch in
der Zivilbevölkerung insgesamt ist die
Moral dadurch gestiegen
hat dieses neue wehrpflichtsystem bei
dem alle mit 18 gefragt werden ob sie
ihren Militärdienst ableisten wollen
aber nur wenige müssen am Ende wirklich
funktioniert das ja
das Ziel ist gerade dass wir 8000
Wehrpflichtige jedes Jahr aufnehmen
und während des aufnahmeprozesses wird
ergründet wer wirklich mitmachen möchte
und wer nicht es wollen aber immer viel
mehr als nötig wäre am Ende haben wir
daher nur diejenigen die auch wirklich
hier dabei sein wollen
und wie geht es den Wehrpflichtigen
Angst vor einem echten Einsatz hätten
sie nicht sagt etwa Simon
ich bin schon stolz meinem Land zu
dienen
wir haben eine wirklich gute
Verteidigung
und sie bringen uns sehr viel bei zum
Beispiel wie man mit Waffen umgeht
viel intensiver sein als in anderen
Ländern habe ich gehört weil Sie uns
vertrauen dass wir machen was wir sollen
in Schweden wird Teamgeist groß
geschrieben der Krieg in der Ukraine hat
die Ansicht bestärkt dass dies auch für
eine moderne Armee wichtig sei diese
Minen Attrappen wiegen zehn Kilo nicht
so ganz leicht und man sie durch die
Landschaft schleppen muss aber die
schwedische Armee macht das schon seit
Jahren so dass die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten langsam in den Dienst
herangeführt werden sie werden langsam
in der Fitness aufgebaut es wird nicht
rumgeschrien ohne Sinn sondern es wird
zusammengearbeitet und durch die
Vorgänge in der Ukraine fühlt man sich
bestätigt es geht darum
zusammenzuarbeiten und keine strikten
befehlstrukturen mir in der russischen
Armee perfektes Englisch auch für
internationale Teamarbeit kein Problem
in Schweden wichtig für die Zukunft denn
nach Jahrhunderten der Bündnisfreiheit
soll Schweden jetzt gemeinsam mit den
Nachbarland Finnland Teil der NATO
werden die Ukraine hat ja von
internationalen Partnern viel
Unterstützung bekommen Munition und
Waffen das ist natürlich auch für
Schweden wichtig Partner mit denen wir
gemeinsam kämpfen und von denen wir
Nachschub bekommen
großen Widerstand gegen das schwedische
Beitrittsgesuch im Mai gab es kaum
selbst die Sozialdemokraten schwenken um
nach dem klar war dass der Nachbar
Finnland beitreten will Schweden und
Finnland erhoffen sich von der
NATO-Mitgliedschaft nicht nur Schutz
erklärt der Militärexperte Jakob
Westberg sie könnten mit modernen Armeen
auch viel zum Bündnis beitragen
wir haben schon seit einigen Jahren
Stück für Stück angefangen unsere
verschiedenen Waffengattungen zu
modernisieren
das fing lange vor dem aktuellen
Kriegsgeschehen an nach der Besetzung
der krimend durch Russland 2014 damals
haben wir wieder angefangen in die
nationale Verteidigung zu investieren
Russland als Bedrohung dass er bei
vielen Schweden eine leicht zu
aktivierende alte Vorstellung meint
Westberg das gilt auch für die Finnen
sie demonstrieren werhaftigkeit nach
einer langen Historie kriegerische
Auseinandersetzung mit Russland so wie
hier in diesem Frühjahr gibt es längst
auch Manöver mit nationalen Partnern
obwohl die Türkei bislang die
Ratifizierung des nato-beitritts
Finnlands und Schwedens blockiert sie
versucht als Gegenleistung für die
Zustimmung eigene Interessen
durchzusetzen bei nur 5 Millionen
Einwohnern hat Finnland inklusive
Reservisten ein Potenzial von fast
900.000 Soldaten in und Soldaten die
aktiviert werden können
wir haben immer konsequent gehandelt
wir haben überall die Jahrzehnte ein
gewisses Niveau aufrecht erhalten
während sich die übrigen europäischen
Länder auf Krisenbewältigung
konzentriert haben
bei uns dagegen stand immer die
nationale Verteidigung im Mittelpunkt
lange war die finnische Öffentlichkeit
gegen eine Bündnis Mitgliedschaft mit
Russlands Angriff auf die Ukraine
schwanger um wir haben bisher war eine
Mehrheit der Finnen gegen die
NATO-Mitgliedschaft aber in diesem
Frühling hat sich alles verändert die
Menschen fühlen sich bedroht auch die
Idee vom Einsatz nicht konventioneller
Waffen verängstigt daher ist die
Verteidigung nicht genug wir brauchen
auch ein Bündnis zur Sicherheit
auch der östliche Nachbar hat stets das
seine um diese Furcht lebendig zu halten
peinlich die Strandung eines
sowjetischen U-Boots in der idyllischen
Inselwelt verstockholm im Oktober 1981
immer wieder hielten Berichte von
sowjetischen und russischen U-Booten
Schweden und die ganze Welt in Atem ein
ganzes Land machte sich auf die Pirsch
nach U-Booten
11 mal führten Russland und Schweden in
der Geschichte Krieg im armee-museum in
Stockholm lagern bis heute erbeutete
Flaggen aus einer Schlacht mit dem
Zarenreich an dieser schmalen Durchfahrt
durch die Scheren stoppten die Schweden
am 13 August 1719 eine russische
Invasionsarmee auf dem Weg nach
Stockholm nachdem diese ganze
Landstriche verwüstet hatte bis heute
finden Anwohner Kanonenkugeln im boten
eigentlich längst vergessen doch der
Historiker und Journalist Johann rohmin
glaubt dass durch den Krieg in der
Ukraine Wunden wieder aufbrechen und
alte Sympathien für Russland
verschwinden
Russland war in den letzten 550 Jahren
eine Bedrohung für Schweden
allerdings gab es auch immer Menschen
die Russland oder die Sowjetunion
unterstützt haben
zum Beispiel während des Kalten Krieges
von Menschen die eher links standen
sie haben regelrecht zu Russland
aufgesehen aber jetzt ist das Misstrauen
gegen Russland gewachsen
und bedrohliche Situation Rücken aktuell
näher es ist zwar weiterhin unklar was
hinter den Beschädigungen der Nord
Stream Gaspipelines Ende September in
der Ostsee steckt doch die EU geht von
bewusster Sabotage aus direkt vor der
schwedischen Küste
der Schutz kritische Infrastruktur er
rückt entsprechend immer mehr in den
Fokus auch der Skandinavien
als würden sie gemeinsam einen Ausflug
in die wildniswagen treffen sich Johann
mietenby und Carl petersängen bei
Stockholm doch ihr Anliegen ist ernst
sie überwachen heute die Übung einer
Truppe die in Schweden seit 1940 eine
besondere Rolle spielt die Hände die
freiwillige heimwerk sie soll auch die
heimische Infrastruktur schützen das
anstehende Manöver koordiniertes
Vorgehen bei einem schweren Unfall es
ist so realistisch wie möglich angelegt
in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten halfen
die freiwilligende Himbeeren vor allem
Zivil etwa bei großen Waldbränden doch
in jüngster Zeit rückt auch eine andere
Aufgabe in den Vordergrund Schweden im
Ernstfall gegen Feinde zu verteidigen
seit dem 24 februar ist die Situation
natürlich ernster geworden aber wir
haben die Landesverteidigung auch früher
als wichtiger Aufgabe wahrgenommen auch
in Zeiten als die reguläre Armee immer
weiter geschrumpft ist da hatten wir das
Gefühl eine wichtige Rolle bei der
Verteidigung zu spielen
was hat sich seit Februar verändert
also jetzt bewerben sich einfach viel
mehr Schweden als früher für die hem
wernett
in meiner Trainingseinheit sind es
tatsächlich 25% mehr
und 5000 würden gerade gerne noch
zusätzlich eintreten
right now
johann ist fester Ausbilder bei der
Hemden in der 22.000 Männer und Frauen
dienen viele haben so wie er auch in der
regulären Armee gedient bei Übungen wie
dieser arbeiten alle zusammen zivile
Rettungsflieger Feuerwehr Ami und Hemme
mit etwas
weil es ist wichtig dass wir uns alle
gegenseitig unterstützen es ist ja klar
dass die Armee nicht genug Ressourcen
hätte um alles alleine zu machen also
arbeiten hier alle zusammen zivile und
militärische Einheiten das sind alles
Profis
Mediziner und Soldaten zum Beispiel und
alle profitieren davon hier zusammen zu
arbeiten
ihre Waffe die sie bei angespannter Lage
auch nach Hause mitnehmen dürfte hat
Anna Lindes den erstmal zur Seite gelegt
die Krankenschwester weiß genau was bei
dieser unfallübung zu tun ist und muss
im Chaos entscheiden wer zuerst
behandelt wird ihren Verdienstausfall
für bis zu 8 Tage Übung bekommt sie
erstattet dennoch war der freiwillige
Dienst in Zeiten der Abrüstung wenig
populär doch das Ansehen hat sich stark
verändert Kräfte aus allen möglichen
zivilen berufen sind im Einsatz
das ist das tolle jeder kommt mit dem
Know-how aus seinem zivilen Leben
hierher mit so viel Erfahrung wir
vereinen das hier alles und heraus kommt
was ganz tolles das ist wirklich
Wahnsinn
als absoluter
ihre Eltern sehen das Engagement mit
unterschiedlichen Gefühlen
Familie was hält deine Familie von dem
Job hier Armin Mama meine Mutter findet
das nicht so toll aber sie ist zumindest
froh dass ich nicht im Ausland arbeite
sondern in Schweden mein Vater findet
den Einsatz aber super also das ist ein
bisschen gemischt
für eine NATO-Mitgliedschaft von
Schweden und Finnland muss die Türkei
noch ihren Widerstand aufgeben ob es
dafür Zugeständnisse etwa im Umgang von
NATO-Staaten mit der kurdischen PKK oder
bei Waffenlieferungen an die Türkei
geben wird ist noch nicht abzusehen und
ob die Hände dann so wie die reguläre
Armee in Schweden Teil der NATO werden
soll ist ebenfalls noch unklar auf jeden
Fall ist die Freiwilligen Armee hoch
motiviert nicht nur bei zivilen
Einsätzen zu helfen sondern auch an der
Seite der regulären Armee zu stehen um
mögliche Feinde abzustrecken und
Schweden gegen Angriffe zu verteidigen
wie lange es noch dauert bis Schweden
und Finnland wirklich in die NATO
eintreten und ob das am Ende alles so
klappt bleibt abzuwarten unterdessen
geht in Frankreich die Angst um dass die
Industrie infolge des Krieges
zusammenbrechen könnte welche sozialen
Folgen das hätte das hat unsere
Korrespondentin Anna Arendt vor Ort
recherchiert
zu guter Letzt abonniert gerne diesen
Kanal damit Ihr unsere Nachrichten aus
dem In- und Ausland nicht verpasst